tcl is predicting a playstation 5 pro
and a new xbox and starfield is getting
the unreal 5 fan treatment
according to polish outlet ppe tcl's
presentation showed the timeline of
consoles starting with the playstation 4
and xbox one in 2013 and their upgraded
counterparts a few years later the
timeline goes on to mention playstation
5 and xbox series x and s in 2020 and
ends with playstation 5 pro and a new
xbox series xns sometime between 2023
and 2024. tcl claims that these consoles
will provide 60 to 120 fps at 4k
resolution as well as having the ability
to display 8k apparently they will also
utilize amd radeon rx 7700 xt technology
now this is potentially just a guess
from tcl as the pattern for mid
generation refreshes seems to happen
about three to four years after the base
console's launch the biggest argument
against the existence of upgraded
consoles is the rampant supply issues
and chip shortages that have been
plaguing the current stock of
playstation 5 and xbox series x and s
manufacturers are still having trouble
meeting the demand for launch consoles
which could make mid-cycle refreshes
both difficult and unneeded at this
stage but to be honest i'm kind of
thinking we might need those upgraded
consoles in order to experience
everything that unreal 5 has to offer
without our playstation 5s and xbox
series x and s is just catching on fire
i say this because today in our new holy
crap that looks sick segment a group of
talented artists have created its own
interpretation of what starfield may
look like if it were to use unreal 5.
the video imagining starfield shows off
impressive alien worlds massive
starships and bustling spaceports all
while a powerful and hopeful score plays
in the background it looks gorgeous
lived-in and breathtaking all at the
same time and certainly sets a tone
starfield however won't actually use
unreal engine 5 but rather bethesda's
creation engine 2 an evolution of the
game engine the studio has previously
used for games like fallout 4 and the
elder scrolls skyrim and speaking of
games with sky in the title no man's sky
has a new update in which time is
slightly broken out today this update
features a roguelite style leviathan
expedition that gives players a single
life to use when they attempt to break
the loop with each death resetting the
timeline and sending them back to square
one the leviathan expedition will run
for approximately six weeks and once it
concludes progress will be converted to
a survival mode save and did i mention
the reward is a huge space whale what
more could you ask for unless you're
asking for a date for that marvel mmo
which
isn't happening anymore the marvel mmo
in development at daybreak games has
been cancelled parent company eg7 said
it decided to cancel the project based
on the re-evaluation of the development
risk profile size of investment and the
long-term product portfolio strategy for
the group now i know daybreak didn't
make marvel's avengers but i wonder if
it's less than stellar reception got eg7
a little worried about tossing an mmo
out there but all right hit the comment
section and let me know what percent
your phone battery is on right now mine
is on 67 and i'll see you tomorrow
you